قلت ان الغاره التي ضربت قوات سوريه كانت
عن طريق الخطا لكن الروس قالوا انها كانت
لتفادي التعاون في سوريا وتسببت بزعزع
الهدنه يمكنهم الحكم كما يشاؤون وقد قاموا
بذلك لكن القرار الاهم الذي يجب عليهم
اتخاذه هو ايقاف الاسد عن قصف الشعب دون
تمييز وهذا ما يستمر بالقيام به وان كانوا
جادين فيما يتعلق باتفاق وقف العمال
العدائيه وهذا ما يقولونه فعليهم منع
الاسد من التحليق واثبات صدقهم حيال الامر
لذا نطلب من روسيا ايقاف التظاهر والسماح
بدخول المساعدات
الانسانيه دخل الاتفاق قيد التنفيذ
الاثنين الماضي ومن المفترض ان تكون حركه
المساعدات انسيابيه لكن النظام يمنعها لذا
فان صديق روسيا الذي تدعمه هو العائق
الاكبر امام القدره للمضي قدما هنا
والمعارضه تشعر بانها مهدده لان القصف
بالقنابل مستمر رغم اتفاق وقف الاعمال
العدائيه روسيا اشتركت في هذا الاتفاق
والاسد قال انه سيلتزم بذلك لذا يجب عليه
التوقف لكي يتم تاسيس مركز التنفيذ
المشترك لتتمكن امريكا وروسيا من التعاون
لتفادي حدوث واقعه فضيعه
مشابهه